dating has definitely changed so
obviously like Tinder and now we have
this new period of only fans I want to
get your thoughts on like what you think
the impact of like only fans will be on
M's perceptions only fans is a recent
phenomenon a lot of women use it what is
only fans is it prostitution not really
because they're generally not having sex
with these guys and let's be honest
these guys that are throwing money at
women to subscribe to their only fans
they're just simps these guys are doing
it under the hopes or the guys that
maybe one day they can meet them or you
know something will happen so it's a
loser's game from that perspective
promiscuity is rampant out there and
women are indulging and men are
indulging and I don't think that's going
to change women are valued based on
their beauty and their purity a woman
that shared her body with a 100 men is
less valuable than a woman that shared
her body with one man for 12 years
because she was in a long-term
relationship so you have to evaluate
these things when you're dealing with
women in your life and be again
fastidious about it and you know
decisive about the kind of women that
you're going to deal
with